bonsoir virginie jourdan merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
l'a dit cinquante sixième jour de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui semble quand même suivre
son cours du côté du gouvernement
quelle est votre réaction là dessus et
pas plus tard que vendredi j'étais au
voeu du procureur du tgi de strasbourg
et en même temps qu'il y avait ce beau
discours il y avait donc effectivement
une manifestation des avocats du barreau
du bas rhin qui manifester leur
mécontentement mais je partage ce
sentiment et je pense que ce sens ce
sentiment est partagé par un grand
nombre de français parce que on le voit
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée de cette
réforme s'aperçoit que c'est du flou
elissa devient de plus en plus illisible
j'entendais cet immense et à
saint-hyacinthe iccat et c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas où on voit on
va on s'aperçoit que le gouvernement le
11 décembre dans la nuit ils décident à
une certaine génération 64 73 à dan 1
minute il décide de mettre en place
cette réforme pour cette génération on
voit que selon les manifestations de
certaines corporatisme il ay arrive à
faire reculer le gouvernement
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
de flou et aujourd'hui les français qui
cotisent tous les mois qui ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois ne n'arrive
pas à se projeter dans l'avenir et le
signal fort en plus très récemment avec
l'avis du conseil d'état
finalement démontre que nous avions
raison que nous dénoncions effectivement
ce trait forme qui a été mise en place à
la va vite dans un coin qu'on nous qu'on
nous vend depuis des mois sous prétexte
qu'un déficit mais j'ai entendu et avec
attention la vie de cet économiste
monsieur ravaux qui disait que si on
vous qui avait les fonds qui a pas de
problème de déficit si on arrivait à
chercher effectivement les fonds là où
il était notamment avec ses 24 milliards
d'euros que l'on pourrait récupérer
après 2025
concernant le remboursement de l'âge
la dette sociale alors ça c'est vrai que
les avis divergent en fonction des
économistes certains estiment qu'il y a
besoin de cette réforme d'autrement une
chose est sûre où vous l'avez évoqué la
vie très critique du conseil d'état
alors on entend des voix là il faut
aussi le mode et en disant c'est vrai
qu'il donne du grain à moudre à tous les
camps si j'ose dire mais tout de même on
voit que le conseil d'état la très haute
juridiction pointe beaucoup beaucoup de
difficulté à laquelle va se confronter
le gouvernement il met en garde le
gouvernement contre justement le flou
autour de cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que selon vous emmanuel macron
doit clairement à la lumière de cette
dernière éléments reculer bien sûr et
doit reculer
et puis même le dès le départ on avait
un avis du corps le conseil
d'orientation de la retraite jeu
honnêtement qui peut dire que c'est
raisonnable de dire qu'il ya un déficit
entre 7 milliards et 10 17 milliards
déjà on a un delta de 10 milliards ce
n'est pas sérieux
je pense que cet avis et 100 et je pense
que le gouvernement doit prendre en
considération cet avis mais aussi les 60
plus de 60% de français sont contre
cette réforme
à un moment donné il faut entendre la
politique ça sert à ça c'est aussi
d'être pragmatique on a une sorte des
chiffres qui sont pas sérieux et
aujourd'hui il doit effectivement
prendre en compte cette grogne des
français qui en plus vivre dans
l'insécurité permanente c'est
inacceptable j'essaie de me passer de
l'autre côté
évidemment chez là pour ça pour vous
pensiez la contradiction emmanuel macron
a quand même été élu démocratiquement
il avait dit qu'il ferait cette retraite
il n'avait il a dit qu'il ne toucherait
pas à l'âge mais qui ferait la retraite
à points aujourd'hui certainement que
lui se dit je suis légitime à la mener à
bout qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui
répondre et effectivement il ya 60% de
français qui sont content mais ces
français ont aussi élu emmanuel macron
peut-être pas à 60% mais le système
aujourd'hui
fait qu'il a été élu président de la
république comme vous l'avez souligné ce
n'était pas dans son programme il avait
bien certifié qui ne toucherait pas à
l'âge légal de la retraite
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'on a un
package qui est floue on ne sait pas
finalement quel est l'âge pivot on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans on ne sait
pas quelle est la valeur du point
aujourd'hui sont incapables de nous
donner une calculatrice pour simuler
notre retraite donc devant cet
amateurisme et aussi par pardon mais
l'élection d' emmanuel macron
effectivement et la gagner mais c'était
pas pour mais c'était contre contre
effectivement notre mouvement mais ce
n'était pas pour mes connaissances à
s'effacer pour d'autres avant lui est ce
qu'on doit changer tout simplement à
notre système électoral la vème
république
finalement ça c'est une c'est à étudier
je pense qu'au delà du choix électoral
je pense que même au niveau de la
réforme des retraites on sait très bien
que ce nouveau mouvement vers la réforme
c'est parce qu'ils étaient allés choisir
chercher sa feuille de route à bruxelles
boxer à l'éclair ça fait des années
qu'elle dit qu'il faut réformer et comme
c'est un bon élève de bruxelles
il nous a donc pondu cette réforme des
retraites qui est très injuste et qui va
vraiment vers l'appauvrissement du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens alors
des bonnes nouvelles quand même sur le
front de l'économie aujourd'hui le
chômage qui a baissé de 3 3% en 2010
neuf en france qui semble toucher toutes
les catégories est ce qu'on peut
l'imputer au moins en partie à emmanuel
macron alors moi je me méfie des
chiffres c'est vrai qu'ils viennent de
sortir faudra voir exactement ce qu'elle
dedans est ce que le chômage de longue
durée ont fait partie je ne crois pas
effectivement il ya eu pas mal de levier
qui font un peu baisser le taux du
chômage c'est qu'il ya eu des plans de
formation que c'est un mouvement
effectivement qui permet de faire
baisser le taux de chômage mais derrière
ces annonces il faut quand même étudier
ces chiffres parce qu'ils sont quand
même où on à 8,6 pour cent de taux de
chômage
je prends pour comparaison l'angleterre
ou l'allemagne sont à quoi 2%
autre actualité vous avez parlé
de bruxelles ça nous conduit directement
au bright side semaine historique pour
le royaume uni qui va se séparer du
reste de l'europe
bientôt la dont le 31 janvier quelle est
votre réaction demain vous allez devoir
vous vous même un voter ratifié donc
c'est cet accord tout à fait aller voter
peau bien sûr ce n'est pas une surprise
nous avons effectivement soutenu cette
démarche toute façon c'est une démarche
démocratique à la base on peut pas aller
contre la volonté du peuple en plus en
plus à côté de ça cela va nous permettre
aussi de gagner 3,3 deux eurodéputés
nous allons passer de la 5e place à la
4ème place nous allons avoir dans plus
de deux comédiens d'activité et aussi de
poids au niveau du parlement parce qu'on
veut être avant les verts c'est assez
important et si c'est à souligner en
fait le quatrième plus grand groupe au
sein du parlement européen
et puis après voilà c'est un cas cet
accord va être va être voté ensuite y
aura des négociations parce que là aussi
ça pas être simple et il faudra suivre
effectivement ce dossier de près
justement michel barnier l'a précisé
qu'il présenterait lundi un projet de
mandat de négociation aux états membres
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez y voir du
côté de rennes
pour l'instant on attend de voir ce que
veut monsieur boris johnson puisque ce
n'est pas clair il va faire son discours
mois de février à savoir quel type
d'accord commercial
il veut mettre en place et en fonction
de ce choix nous verrons nous si c'est
toujours dans l'intérêt
des français ou pas puisque c'est ça
notre boussole d'abord michel barnier on
sent qu'à de la fébrilité quand même qui
met en garde contre une rupture brutale
des échanges à ce qu'on peut le craindre
parce que beaucoup de secteurs quand
même le craignent savez c'est comme au
poker il ya beaucoup de bluff ce sont on
est dans une phase de négociation donc
dans ces négociations il va y avoir des
jeux de cartes des bluffs dd com comme
toi paix est avec nous avec les gaffes à
où effectivement vous avez vu les
négociations ont fait peur et après on
revient sur des à quoi donc on est dans
une phase de négociations donc tout est
possible tout est permis
ce qu'il faudra trouver à la fin c'est
un équilibre est toujours toujours notre
objectif c'est l'intérêt des français
boris johnson lui en tout cas voit bien
l'intérêt des britanniques
ville beurre l'argent du beurre la
crémière autorise johnson des droits de
douane sur les voitures allemandes et
les fromages français seraient très mal
ça veut dire justement qu'il ya ce côté
beurre et l'argent du beurre
l'union européenne risquent de sortir
quand même perdant de ce divorce il ya
ce risque tout de même c'est là qu'on va
voir l'utilité de l'union européenne
c'est là qu'on va voir si vraiment elle
et elle sert à quelque chose
c'est là qu'on va voir si elle a du
poids et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
verra si nous français on arrive à tirer
notre épingle du jeu dans l'actualité
également
évidemment les 75e anniversaire de la
libération du camp d'auschwitz avec les
diverses commémorations voulez vous
faire réagir ce sera l'objet de notre
débat tout à l'heure déjà ce parallèle
qui a fait bondir du côté des rendus et
rennes mais aussi de de la droite plus
traditionnelle l'est républicain le
parallèle entre shoah et colonisation
algérienne pour emmanuel macron quelle
est votre réaction
je souhaite c'est inadmissible et c il
est déjà en campagne électorale
voilà il joue sur tous les tableaux il
attise la haine il
il est dans la division et ce n'est pas
la hauteur d'un chef d'état il faut
laisser la mémoire et la shoah telle
qu'elle est
il faut pas mettre ça sur le même pied
d'égalité on peut très bien s'adresser à
tous nos concitoyens sans faire de la
surenchère et je trouve que vraiment
c'est pas la hauteur d'un chef d'état
pour vous il ya aucune sincérité quand
il nous parle de ça parce qu'il en avait
parlé également un crime contre
l'humanité pendant sa campagne savait
déjà bondir ses rangs des manoeuvres
électorales pour vous pour moi c'est
effectivement des manoeuvres électorales
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez il en
difficulté on a encore vu les derniers
sondages ça ne fait que baisser
d'ailleurs depuis qu'il est président ça
baisse je me demande jusqu'où on va
aller parce que ça ne fait que baisser
je pense comme il l'a dit
il est en campagne électorale donc il
faut qu'ils séduisent un électorat et
comme vous l'avait dit il l'a dit
pendant les élections présidentielles
et là il ressort maintenant clairement
il se sert de ces événements tragiques
pour lui et pour faire sa campagne
aujourd'hui à une augmentation de 130 %
du nombre de faits racistes et
xénophobes en france en 2010 9
augmentation également spécifiquement de
l'antisémitisme 27% par rapport à 2018
est ce qu'on prend le problème dans le
du côté de du bon côté en france pour
lutter contre ce fléau
déjà il faut regarder ce qu'il ya dedans
c'est vrai que les premiers persécutés
en france enfin si on peut dire comme
les victimes sont quand même les actes
anti chrétiens ensuite c'est vrai que ce
sont les actes antisémites et à la fin
donc les actes anti musulmans je pense
qu'on est dans un dans un climat qui et
quand je lui ai dit de division où on
attise la haine ou malgré la lutte parce
qu'il ya quand même
des associations il ya des pôles qui
font que il ya c'est un sujet qui
revient tout le temps mais manifestement
n'y a pas les moyens je prends juste les
cas le cas de tumeurs de madame halimi
honnêtement c'est quoi cette décision
qu'elle signale on donne ci parce que
sous prétexte on fume du cannabis
on ne peut pas être traduit en justice
les juges ont appelé emmanuel macron sur
ce point à respecter leur indépendance
soit c'est une bien sûr résumé peut-être
une décision judiciaire mais elle n'est
pas moral à mon sens quel signal on
donne aux jeunes quand on y est busan ça
sera ma dernière question nous dit
marine le pen n'est pas la bienvenue
pour parler du nazisme et que j'ai envie
de lui répondre mais madame busin on
vous entend pas sur la gestion du
coroner virus et puis pareil à l'est
aussi en campagne ils nous font ils
veulent faire peur aux gens toujours
nous a ramenés à cette époque
moi je trouve que c'est une insulte moi
mon grand père est un il a eu la
médaille des évadés et je pense qu'une
grande partie de notre électorat pareil
a eu des parents des grands parents qui
ont été résistants je l'invite à
regarder aussi dans notre mouvement
beaucoup de personnalités ont été des
résistants je pensais mais se devait de
monsieur de camaret donc là aussi on est
dans la surenchère électorale où il faut
nous insulter pour exister
merci beaucoup virginie joron eurodéputé
membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national d'avoir été avec
nous